all right let's talk crypto for a second
this is ready for the crypto corner so
look we all have that one friend
that he's giving you hot stock tips or
financial advice or investment advice or
you got to get in on dogecoin bro
bitcoins going on the moon or this is
gonna happen
and you're like buddy aren't you broke
and living with your mom still and 27
years old
i don't know i think i'm good on your
advice i'm not sure i should be
listening to you however
the person giving this advice that we're
about to talk about is an actual
billionaire
and when they drop some knowledge you
might want to pay attention and take a
look so here's this article from market
watch
billionaire john paulson
predicts cryptocurrencies will all
go
to zero dun dun dun
what's dude talking about here here's
the article
cryptocurrencies according to john
paulson regardless of where they're
trading today will eventually prove to
be
worthless once the exuberance wears off
or liquidity dries up they will all go
to zero i wouldn't recommend anyone
invest in cryptocurrencies says paulson
he's the president portfolio manager
hedge fund manager of the us investment
firm paulson and company paulson said it
wasn't even worth shorting bitcoin
because it's extremely extremely
volatile and instead suggests investors
stock money into bullion which is
basically gold
due to a very limited amount of
investable
gold paulson sees investors pulling
money out of fixed income which are
bonds and cash cash as inflation rises
then heading towards the only logical
destination and that is
gold
oh
my god okay
so for those that are not familiar with
this guy john paulson he became super
famous
during the great recession uh the hedge
fund manager made a killing betting
against the u.s housing market uh the
name became very familiar um
after with the movie the big short and
michael um
michael bury big short yeah uh played by
um
uh
who played michael berry in the in the
middle let's look it up michael burry
please the actor who played batman
christian bale christian bale all right
he's next i was in the big short clue
yeah christian bale batman right here
exactly yeah so that's how that's how
paul made his name so when a billionaire
basically says look
crypto zero good luck out there get out
there get into gold
right um
maybe you listen i don't know exactly so
losano commented he doesn't agree he
goes this guy's a this guy's a full
capital fool he needs a kiss you know
that this guy's a fool not just a
regular fool capital capital f
o o l
thank you zachary for your two cents so
paulson basically says look if you've
got all this cash lying around maybe
you buy your own house that's that's
what he's saying put it into
hard assets
um
i like this one sometimes the old dog
does not like does not understand new
tricks that's from our guy zachary who
called him he said
um
so that was the article and i said all
right
we'll take that for what it's worth
that's one man's opinion
who has a different opinion that i'd
like to hear and this is where i found
this article
um from arc
invest
kathy wood arc investment kathy arc
investment management kathy wood she's
the founder and ceo of arc investment
she's like a
uh
investing rock star these days they pull
up a picture of of of sweet kathy wood
kathy wood she said i look hey john i
hear you buddy i saw your article
here's my response
here's what i got to tell you
john paulson in that response fool you
check yourself she says
uh i'm a believer in bitcoin and the
entire world of decentralized currency
so now we have two basically billionaire
types yeah that are just giving
different opinions so in a recent
interview with yahoo finance kathy woods
said there's a key aspect that gold bugs
she calls now this is like trash talking
oh you're a gold bug dog that gold bugs
like john paulson are missing
when it comes to evaluating bitcoin as
an asset she says
bitcoin is much more than digital gold
you got it all wrong john paulson she
says quote unquote many investors who
have spent their careers focused on gold
cannot understand the digital concept
associated with gold aka bitcoin
what we think paulson is missing is
this is much more than the store of
value or digital gold she's basically
saying look i hear you paulson
but you're wrong go kick some rocks okay
she says bitcoin in particular is the
new global monetary system wow it's a
rules-based monetary policy which is
completely decentralized and therefore
is not subject to the whims of
policymakers in fact
it's a hedge against the whims of
policymakers especially in emerging
markets so the question is this friends
out there on valuetainment friends out
there of the sas cast
we've given you two different
perspectives regarding bitcoin and
cryptocurrency
who
do you agree with
john paulson
billionaire hedge fund manager old
school guy
relatively old school dude or kathy wood
who's probably 60 yourself but sort of
on that new school thought process she
thinks bitcoin is the wave of the future
one totally against one totally four
leave us your comments below we're gonna
be checking them david let us know your
thoughts on that and while i'm doing
that let me give you my two cents
one is completely against and one is
completely for bitcoin here's the um
here's my response you don't have to be
on either side
of the bitcoin or either side of the
coin to use the the correct pawn right
there
you could be
you know you can dip your toe in the
water a little bit like for instance
i've been very clear
when i was investing and diversifying
and bitcoin became a thing for me when i
started to understand it in 2017 i took
five percent of my liquid
uh
assets of in my portfolio that i was
willing to just kind of play with
and put it in bitcoin and it's to prove
to be very well for me now if i would
have sold when it plummeted and i would
have lost money i'd maybe have a
different perspective but i've hold i've
held i've huddled and it's turned out
very nice so
i did a whole bitcoin episode on one one
of my first valuetainment economics
things um we moved here to to boca south
florida and i said just do what the big
boys are doing
do what the big boys are doing and what
are the big boys doing they're somewhat
putting somewhere between five and eight
percent of their portfolio in the crypto
so you don't got to be a hundred percent
you don't have to be zero percent maybe
your number that you're comfortable with
is five percent maybe it's 10 maybe it's
20
maybe like steph curry you can put
.001 percent of your net worth into a
nft
um
with the ape that he bought what was
that called again the board ape
so
look
you don't have to be all in or all out
you can dabble in it and last week we
talked about
how to invest in crypto without actually
investing in crypto and you can invest
in companies that indirectly invest in
crypto ie tesla nvidia
square jack dorsey their payment
platform
um
if i had to pick one whether bitcoin was
going to zero
or is going to be worth a million
dollars one day
i'm on the side of kathy wood here i'm
not saying that it's guaranteed to go
there there's no guarantee but it's all
risk and reward so what are people
saying out there in the comments people
are going with both people are i saw
saying kathy yeah meryl b chose kathy
uh
um a lot yeah mostly it's both
we got some both okay manny gg you gotta
pay them anyway so that's the crypto
is corner if you enjoyed that short clip
from the sauce cast click here to watch
another click here to watch the full
episode or just stay broken